six figure discussions dinners in public
my line and all tailored my outstanding
payments swift like taylor and boy i owe
them men are beating welcome to tick
tock taylor i'm just here to have fun
taylor swift posted her first ever video
to the app on monday announcing that the
red taylor's version vinyl album will be
available on november 19th and as a
thank you to her new social media
community tick tock users can buy the
pre-sale for the vinyl now i'm so
excited she set the clip to the song
screw face capital by uk rapper dave who
name drops her in the lyrics and
captioned it in part quote lots going on
at the moment let the games begin
hashtag swifftalk six figure discussions
dinners in public my line and all
tailored my outstanding payments swift
like taylor and boy i owe them men are
beating earlier this month the 31 year
old grammy winner confirmed that she's
collaborating with a few artists on her
re-recordings but most of her fans had
already figured that out based on clues
she had been dropping on social media
how'd i do that quote i know some of you
thought that would be like trying to
solve a crossword and realizing there's
no right answer but you played it good
and right congrats pals you guessed the
correct titles and feature artists on
red my version she added that the vault
tracks will feature chris stapleton
phoebe bridgers mark foster and the
first song ed sheeran and taylor ever
wrote together the first time they met
in 2012. quote i can't express my
gratitude enough to these artists for
helping me bring these songs to life i
can't wait till we can dust off our
highest hopes and relive these memories
together it's been amazing
loving it and taylor said fans can look
forward to new songs too writing that
red taylor's version includes so many
songs you haven't heard yet and she
wrapped it all up writing that until
then quote i'll be counting down and
picturing it all in my head in burning
red you never know what it's gonna be
and in the meantime we'll just be here
waiting for taylor to drop her next tick
tock six figure discussions dinners in
public my linen all tailored my
outstanding payments swift like taylor
and boy i owe them men are beating